ce matin les stigmates des violences
urbaines sont encore visibles dans le
quartier des saugeraies car depuis
mercredi des affrontements sporadiques
avec les forces de l'ordre se
multiplient et même les pompiers lors de
leurs interventions sont visés par des
projectiles
c'était le cas hier soir lorsque le
groupe scolaire jules ferry était
l'objet de trois tentatives d' incendies
de l'extérieur on ne voit rien car les
dég intérieur seraient minimes nous
avons rencontré des jeunes qui acceptent
tout à fait de discuter avec la
municipalité une réunion aura lieu dans
le début de la semaine prochaine et
qu'il faut pas faire l'amalgamme de tous
les jeunes certains ne cautionne pas
bien évidemment les faits qui ont eu
lieu d'autant plus que c'est plus par
amp destruction partielle d'une salle du
temps après l'école c'est à dire que
c'est des propres enfants du quartier
qui seront pénalisés et cela est
inadmissible et l'embrasement de ces
dernières nuits fait suite à une
opération de police qui a démonté un
lieu de vente à la sauvette notamment
pour des sandwichs il s'agissait d'une
toile de tente qui étaient installés
dans la rue oui avec un certain nombre
de mobiliers qui qui meublaient 70 à un
bar quelques quelques canapés quelques
quelques structures modulaires pour
l'heure aucune interpellation n'a eu
lieu
mais des enquêtes sont ouvertes pour
identifier les auteurs de ces multiples
dégradations